right Badawi is imprisoned in a cell
without daylight his crime advocating
freedom of speech in his homeland Saudi
Arabia in 2008 the blogger founded the
free Saudi Liberals platform here he
argued for a secular and liberal Society
in Saudi Arabia in 2012 he was arrested
the charge insulting Islam the
punishment 10 years in prison and 1,000
lashes this cell phone video shows the
first public whipping of Badawi last
January German Foreign Minister
frank-walter Steinmeier appealed for Bo
Dollis release at a visit by his Saudi
counterpart in August to no avail
wedowee zwei fin saath hai der fled with
their three children into exile in
Canada because of her commitment to
Badawi her family broke off all contact
with her and now Holly I'm filled with
longing and pain I love for four years
I've had to live far away from my
husband that I and we did nothing wrong
my children are forced to grow up
without a father reife did nothing to
deserve a punishment this harsh our
situation is really very bad Saudi
authorities banned badal ways blog in
the country long ago but his words also
exist as a book and that's not as easy
to delete